what if you could walk on water walking
on water would require defying the laws
of physics specifically the property of
surface tension scientists have been
exploring ways to achieve this feat for
years from using special shoes to
harnessing the power of air bubbles to
support our weight if we could Master
the technique it would have incredible
applications for making rescue
operations easier to revolutionizing
water sports like surfing and
wakeboarding however the consequences of
walking on water could also have
significant implications for the
environment walking on water could
potentially allow us to walk on delicate
ecosystems without damaging them they
can also change the way we interact with
water bodies and affect their ecology as
for how it might happen scientists are
studying the properties of surface
tension and ways to manipulate it to
make walking on water a reality